Ryan Gosling hits the red carpet a day  after news broke that he and longtime  love Ava Mendes secretly welcomed baby  number two thank you so much 35 year old  actor attended the LA premiere of his  new movie the nice guys on Tuesday after  keeping one of Hollywood's best kept  secrets oh that game though he didn't  talk about his new bundle of joy Amata  he did smile pretty big at the mention  of his baby girl when ET spoke to the  proud new Papa on the red carpet a  reality want to say congratulations on  your new baby girl it's a wonderful  thing thank you so much right it's just  a so impressed you could be able to keep  that a secret we don't know how you did  it well thank you very much the nice  guys hits theaters May twentieth